[Musique]
et pourtant elle tourne
si des faits ne correspondent pas à la
théorie changer les faits rien ne se
perd rien ne se crée tout se transforme
contes en commun ces trois citations et
bien elles sont tout simplement
apocryphe c'est-à-dire foz ou notes
attribuées à leurs véritables auteurs
tout ce n'est que la pointe de l'iceberg
tellement les fausses citations sont
nombreuses sur le web peut être vous
êtes vous déjà fait prendre sans le
savoir
pierre ferland citations aux fausses
citations pour ce genre de truc est à
classifier dans la catégorie pause
nouvel hobby qui regagne constamment à
toutes les sauces dans un lieu classé la
fausse assurent une personne célèbre
d'un personnage historique on voit
beaucoup sur les réseaux sociaux donc je
me suis même fait un jeu avec moi même
chaque fois que je vois un image avec
une citation d'un personnage historique
je fais une petite recherche et je me
rends compte que c'est pas vrai dire
aucune preuve que cette personne le haut
c'est tout un 10 10 citations qui parle
comme du monde aujourd'hui donc il
souhaitait des personnes nées des
personnages historiques qui ont pris de
l'avenir qui ont exactement comment ça
allait se passer aujourd'hui nostradamus
ou qu'il aborde et les opinions en vogue
de nos jours comme ça voire paquet
circuler l'étude de trois exemples de
nous donner le bon vieux classique c'est
george orwell qui a pris dix
l'utilisation des téléphones mobiles
citation complètement ils vont hanter ya
jamais jamais prononcé ces mots là une
autre qui est vraiment populaire aussi
c'est une prestation de l'ancien premier
scan haddaoui fier de leur vie où ils
semblent dire que les immigrants doivent
s'adapter à nos valeurs et apprendre
l'anglais le français en fait cette
citation de l'ancien président des états
unis d'or aux textes en charge de
l'écologie pour canada et on a mis le
nom de wii fit et de la vie c'est
tellement cour a comme phénomène qu'il
ya des gens qui s'amusent à ironiser sur
ce phénomène là donc sa famille
on voit abraham lincoln qui dit ne
croyais pas tout ce que vous lisez sur
internet s'ajoutent à la con mais ça
fait tellement partie dans
l'environnement des réseaux sociaux qui
est des gens qui s'amusent à se moquer
d'eux quel est l'ingrédient qui fait que
ça marche autant que ça circule autres
parce que plein de gens qui tombent dans
le piège
ça nous fait plaisir de voir qu'un
personnage historique avait la même
opinion que nous mais aussi simplement
le fait que c'est facile à créer des
fausses citations des contenants en
train de faux tour d'un personnage
historique ont écrit des textes et voilà
le tour est chouette mais qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire justement pour détecter
ces cas-là de fausses citations mr et
dans un truc tout simplement ne cherche
qu courson qui comprend la station la
base aux prestations l'écrit dans google
qu'elle entre 600 stations qui ferment
vos bonnes sources on travaille pour
cette personne ne dise à telle date
le congrès pendant dix corps où cette
personne ait iris aux dentelles livre
qu'on craint c'est pas fiable ça va être
les premiers résultats ça va être des
sites de citations inspirante l'on donne
jamais de sources ont dit jamais d'où ça
provient donc on se méfie des citations
le parce que souvent ces sédiments dans
le fond il on se rend compte que ces
citations love c'est quelqu'un d'autre
qui les ai dit où est donc vraiment ça
on n'a pas de sens on sait pas
exactement d'où ça vient on partage donc
si on gratte un peu surpris en jouant
peut-être en grande quantité ce petit
grand chose
[Musique]